Ich bin Saskia (28)
und Informatiktrainerin für
Sehbehinderte im beruflichen Umfeld.
Ich mache die nächsten vier Wochen
ein Experiment
zum Thema Selbstvermessung.
Dazu nutze ich Apps und Gadgets,
v.a. in den Bereichen Fitness,
Ernährung und Erholung.
So möchte ich sehen, wie ich
mein Leben damit optimieren kann.
Ich habe mich
vor einigen Monaten verletzt.
Ich komme jetzt gerade
aus einer Verletzungsphase raus,
darf jetzt also wieder
mit Sport starten.
Ich möchte in dreieinhalb Wochen
beim Spartacus Run in Sursee
mitlaufen.
Das sind etwa 6,5 km
mit mindestens 20 Hindernissen.
Da muss ich was tun.
Wenn ich mich nicht optimiere,
schaffe ich das nicht.
Ich fülle meine Excel-Liste aus,
um meine Ziele zu definieren
und die dann zu überprüfen.
Ich würde gerne versuchen,
mindestens 7 Std. zu schlafen,
damit ich beim Sport fitter werde.
Und ich möchte 6 kg abnehmen.
Ich messe drei Bereiche:
Fitness, Ernährung und Erholung.
Es sind ja schon viele Daten,
die ich persönlich sammeln möchte.
Und ...
Ja, da schaue ich, wie ich das
am besten darstellen kann.
Ich hätte am Schluss
auch gerne ein Diagramm,
was mir farblich zeigt,
wo ich stehe
und was ich noch machen muss.
Und ich möchte auch wissen,
was ich überhaupt schaffe.
Es ist ganz klar eine Selbst-
reflexion und Motivation für mich.
Und ich mag es gerne aufgeschrieben,
was ich mache und tun muss.
Ich hab gerne Hilfe -
Hilfe von den Apps.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich würde gerne Gewicht verlieren
und meine Ausdauer steigern.
Und daher an Trainingstagen
1'700 Kalorien.
Und wenn ich jetzt mal nichts mache
oder weniger,
dann auch weniger Kalorien.
Ich koche jetzt eine Shakshuka.
Ich stelle meine Ernährung
dahingehend um,
dass ich weniger Kohlenhydrate esse.
Das kennt jeder.
Aber was ich Besonderes
machen möchte:
Ich möchte auf Getreide,
Milchprodukte
und komplett auf Zucker verzichten.
Die Technik und Vermessung
helfen mir dabei zu sehen,
was überhaupt
in den Lebensmitteln drin ist.
Ich habe jetzt gerade
meine Ernährungstrack-App geöffnet,
um meine Zutaten einzugeben
und zu scannen.
Sie hat mich schon daran erinnert,
dass ich mein Abendessen
eingeben soll.
Also, das passt gerade.
Ich kann das hier jetzt scannen.
Mal schauen, ob es das gibt.
Ich halte es unter die Handykamera.
Ja, dann wird mir das angezeigt.
Ich kann dann entscheiden,
ob das richtig ist.
Und ich kann auch
die Portionen aussuchen.
Das war jetzt ein Tablespoon.
Eine Paprika z.B. ist
in einer normalen Grösse hinterlegt.
Ich könnte sie auch wiegen.
Das wäre noch besser.
Die würde ich dann einzeln eingeben.
So gibt es dann eben
das Gericht insgesamt.
Und so weiss ich ganz genau,
wie viele Kalorien drin sind,
ohne dass ich mich darauf
verlassen muss, was draufsteht.
Hey, Siri!
* Klingelzeichen *
(Weibliche Computerstimme)
Schiess los!
Timer: 10 Min.
* Klingelzeichen *
Okay, 10 Min. -
und der Countdown läuft.
Meine Ernährung umzustellen
fällt mir in gewisser Weise schwer.
Ich würde lügen,
wenn ich sagen würde:
"Nö, das ist alles easy!"
Ich glaube, die ersten paar Tage
sind gar nicht so schlimm,
denn dann ist die Motivation
noch sehr gross, das durchzuziehen.
Schlimm wird es erst,
wenn man unterwegs ist und merkt:
"Oh,
jetzt sollte ich eigentlich essen!"
Und alles, was ich bekomme,
z.B. beim Bäcker,
darf ich nicht essen,
weil kein Getreide.
Und dann
fällt es einem schon schwer.
Ich komme aus einer Verletzung.
Genauer habe ich mir vor vier Wochen
ein Aussenband im Fuss gerissen.
Und davor hatte ich eine schwere
Schädel- und Halswirbelprellung
durch einen Reitunfall.
Und jetzt ist heute das erste Mal,
wo ich wieder laufen gehe.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es läuft.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Here with me.
Ich tracke meine Zielsetzungen
im Fitness
erst einmal mit einer App ...
... und mit einem Gerät,
das die ganzen Parameter misst.
Das wäre in diesem Fall meine Uhr.
Gemessen wird mein Herzschlag.
Gemessen wird mit GPS,
welche Strecke ich laufe.
Und meine Pace.
Das bedeutet,
wie schnell ich überhaupt bin.
Und daran
würde ich mich gerne messen.
Meine grösste Motivation
ist natürlich,
möglichst schnell Ergebnisse
zu sehen und fit zu werden.
Man kann immer sagen:
"Jetzt bin ich besser geworden
und fühle mich besser."
Aber letztlich zählt nur das,
was gemessen wurde.
* Sie keucht. *
Ähm ...
2 km.
Dauer: 12 Min. 51 Sek.
Eine Pace von 6,22 -
also wie viele Minuten ich
für einen Kilometer brauche.
Und ...
Ich habe 238 Kalorien verbrannt.
Und meine Herzfrequenz
war im Durchschnitt bei 177.
Das ist noch ein bisschen hoch.
Der maximale Puls
ist bei mir bei 185.
D.h.,
dann kriege ich keine Luft mehr.
Und er könnte noch
ein bisschen stabiler unten sein.
Aber fürs Erste
ist es schon mal gut.
# Go, motivate, motivate,
motivate, motivate, motivate.
Ich habe auch noch etwas angehängt -
einfach, um zu schauen,
was noch geht und wo mein Limit ist.
Meine Date
wurde bereits in der App gesammelt.
Das habe ich vorhin kontrolliert.
Das steht alles drin.
Ich werde sie zusätzlich noch
in meine Motivation Chart einfügen.
Und ich bin selbst überrascht,
dass ich das geschafft habe.
# Motivate, motivate,
motivate, motivate, motivate.
Der erste Tag war für mich
wirklich sehr überraschend.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl gehabt,
ich kenne mich aus,
was zumindest die Apps betrifft.
V.a. bin ich überrascht
über meinen Run,
dass es so gut lief,
dass ich danach noch Puste hatte.
Und es gibt mir auch Hoffnung,
dass das Ganze
wirklich in der Zeit klappt,
wie ich mir das vorgenommen habe.
Heute treffe ich mich mit Christoph,
um zu rennen
und Kraftübungen zu machen.
Zu zweit
macht es einfach mehr Spass!
14!
Zehn!
Neun!
In Bezug auf Sport
läuft es sehr, sehr gut.
Ich habe ja
mit meinen 2 km angefangen
und das auch
wirklich gerade so geschafft.
Mit meinem Laufplan
bin ich gestern schon 4,5 km
in einer sehr guten Pace gelaufen.
Und jetzt fehlt einfach
noch ein bisschen die Kraft.
* Popmusik *
Die Selbstvermessung
hilft mir in dem Fall sehr gut,
um mich zu motivieren.
Ich habe meinen Plan.
Meine App sagt mir,
wann ich zu laufen habe,
v.a. aber auch,
was ich zu laufen habe.
Und wenn ich das nicht so mitmesse
und nach dem Plan mache,
wäre keine Steigerung
und Entwicklung zu sehen.
Und da hilft mir das wahnsinnig!
* Sie keucht. *
Ich kriege keine Luft mehr.
Danke dir!
Puh! Besser!
Wie viel sind wir jetzt gerannt?
- Das kann ich dir zeigen.
Und zwar ...
Wir müssen noch das Foto machen.
Für unser ... Doch!
Können wir das
nicht jeweils vorher machen?
Nein, das ist extra ...
Das Foto nach dem Rennen
ist extra dazu da, dass man sieht,
was man geleistet hat.
Ich finde das die beste Motivation.
- Ja, ja.
Also,
dann machen wir mal ein Selfie!
Yeah!
- Sehr gut!
Man kann noch eine Notiz hinzufügen
und sagen: "Es war super."
Und dann liest sie es uns vor.
(Computerstimme) Distanz: 2,3 km.
Dauer: 14 Min. 40 Sek.
Durchschnittliche Pace:
6 Min. 21 Sek.
Gut!
- Genau.
Und hier auf dieser Karte
kannst du immer noch erkennen,
an welcher Stelle ich jetzt z.B.,
weil es meinen Puls mass,
im höchsten Pulsbereich war -
also eigentlich wirklich k.o. war.
Und immer, wo es hochging,
sieht man,
wo es runterging,
wie es wieder grün wurde.
Und so
tracke ich jetzt jedes Rennen.
Man kann hier
auch noch den Fortschritt anzeigen.
Und dann sehe ich hier z.B., wie
viele Kilometer ich gelaufen bin,
welche Pace ich im Schnitt habe
und wie viele Kilometer
ich gesamt gelaufen bin.
Mein Jahresziel sind 150 km.
18 davon bin ich schon gelaufen.
Der Fakt, dass mir die App sagt, was
ich zu tun habe, finde ich genial.
Sie schlägt mir einfach etwas vor.
Ich halte mich daran.
Und schlussendlich
kann ich mich darauf verlassen.
Es macht es für mich viel einfacher,
weil ich einfach dem folge,
was mir die App sagt.
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden
und wurde
von meiner Sleep-Cycle-App geweckt -
wie in den letzten paar Wochen auch.
Wenn ich sie abends stelle,
muss ich nur sagen,
wann ich spätestens
aufwachen möchte.
Und dann rechnet sie
im Halbstundenzyklus und schaut,
wann ich am wachsten bin.
Dann fängt sie an, mich zu wecken -
also wie ein ganz normaler Wecker.
Die App trackt zusätzlich
noch meinen Schlaf.
D.h., sie hört mir nachts zu
und kann durch diese Geräuschkulisse
entscheiden,
wie meine Schlafphase im Moment ist.
Dann zeige ich am besten mal,
was die App alles kann.
Ich nehme mal den Schlaf
von heute Nacht.
Da hatte ich die Möglichkeit,
relativ lange zu schlafen.
Das wirkte sich auch
auf die Schlafqualität aus.
Und ...
Ja, die Herzfrequenz
wird morgens eben auch gemessen -
und zwar geht hinten bei der Kamera
das Licht an.
Das Kameralicht und die Kamera
können meinen Herzschlag nachmessen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob die App
den Schlaf wirklich verbessern kann.
Mein grösster Gewinn von der App
ist,
dass ich besser aufwache
und mich so dann auch fitter fühle.
Und ich bin in Bezug auf meinen
Schlaf viel aufmerksamer geworden.
Bubele!
Hallo!
Komm mal her!
Oh Mausi!
Grosses Pferd!
Ja, komm her!
Für mich ist mein Pferd
der einzige Ort,
an dem ich tatsächlich
digital frei bin.
Und deswegen zählt es für mich
v.a. zur Erholung,
weil ich hier
auch mal abschalten kann.
Also ich bin vor zwei Monaten
vom Pferd gefallen.
Ich war auch im Krankenhaus.
Aber es ist für mich ...
... eher die Motivation
zu überdenken:
Was könnte ich denn
noch besser machen?
Wie könnte ich
solche Situationen vermeiden?
Wir gehen hoch auf den Platz.
Er ist noch nicht eingeritten.
Wir arbeiten im Moment
gerade vom Boden aus
und gewöhnen ihn an den Sattel.
Aber es reicht noch nicht,
um frei zu reiten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Komm!
Gut! Prima!
Super!
In meinem Motivation Chart steht,
was ich mir vorgenommen habe und ...
Ja, es gleicht sich immer mehr ab
mit dem,
was ich auch erreicht habe.
Meine grossen Ziele pro Kategorie
waren ja,
dass ich beim Sport fitter werde.
Das habe ich tatsächlich geschafft.
Zum Thema Ernährung sagte ich,
ich wolle 6 kg abnehmen.
Das ist in dreieinhalb Wochen
schon ein bisschen ein krasses Ziel.
Heute Morgen habe ich mich gewogen.
Und ich habe es tatsächlich
geschafft!
Mein Ziel in der Erholung
mit den 7 Std. Schlaf im Schnitt
habe ich auch mit heute
oder gestern schon geschafft.
Das Experiment Selbstvermessung
führte v.a. dazu,
dass ich immer irgendwie
einen Leitfaden hatte,
was ich machen soll, muss und kann.
Kritik an der Selbstvermessung
kann ich eigentlich
nur in dem Punkt geben,
dass man halt sehr, sehr, sehr viel
von sich preisgibt.
Man kann nicht so ganz
kontrollieren,
wo die Daten landen.
Und v.a. verbringt man natürlich
viel Zeit am Handy.
Das sind meine Freunde
jetzt gewöhnt,
aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es für jemanden,
der das auch gerne versuchen würde,
schwierig sein kann,
denn es kommt viel Druck von aussen.
Das fängt an mit:
"Was trackst du da?
Was machst du da die ganze Zeit?"
"Du schreibst das auf und wiegst
dich mit einer komischen Waage!"
"Was ist,
wenn die Daten rauskommen?"
Ich glaube, es ist eher das Problem,
dass einen die Unsicherheit
von aussen selber unsicher macht.
Das waren meine Goals,
das, was ich erreichen wollte.
Und heute werde ich am Run sein.
Es wird erst abgehakt,
wenn ich es geschafft habe.
* Popmusik *
* Jubel *
* Sie keucht. *
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
Aber ich ...
Ich bin froh,
dass ich es gemacht habe -
jetzt in dreieinhalb Wochen.
Mir fehlen ein bisschen die Worte.
Ich glaube,
das heute hat mir gezeigt,
dass sich das lohnt,
dass man dadurch
Ziele realistischer erreichen kann.
Ich habe sie
in meinen Alltag eingebaut.
Warum sollte ich es nicht machen?
Ich würde gerne jedem zeigen,
dass es sich lohnt, das anzufangen,
wenn es auch nur mal
für einen Monat ist,
um zu sagen:
"Okay, ich habe das mal gemacht."
Es war sauanstrengend,
aber es hat Spass gemacht!